tensions are flaring between armenia and
azerbaijan after decades-long ceasefire
broke down
and even though those nations are a
world away many from right here in las
vegas are hurting as a result of that
conflict
and they warn if it doesn't stop the
impact could be felt all over the world
sasha loftis joining us live from the
southwest valley where a vigil was held
tonight
denise and brian the violence in armenia
isn't just destroying the country
it's also devastating with those with
ties here in las vegas
a group came together tonight to stand
with those who have died
they're also pushing for change in hopes
that the region can achieve peace
[Music]
the silence of the world to us is
deafening
it's a sound of sadness that echoes for
seven thousand miles
as this group in las vegas griefs for
its homeland
we as armenians are concerned about our
homeland about our people over there and
also that this could
really start a global issue dozens
gathered to push for peace in armenia
friday
as reignited conflict continues between
the caucasus country
and neighboring azerbaijan they're
bombing civilians
churches and schools and they need to be
held accountable hundreds have died
and those here don't just worry about
the thousands of others in danger
but the threat of history repeating
itself
it's reminiscent of the genocide
armenian genocide of 1915
committed by the ottoman turks that's
why they're speaking out
asking local and national governments to
intervene
we want our senators our congress people
to effectuate policy change by the white
house
and the state department to take action
and
stop what's going on all while using
this passion and power
to inspire change from an entire world
away
we're stronger than turkey we're
stronger than azerbaijan and together we
can take a stand
now so far the local armenian-american
community has raised about 600
thousand dollars that will go to
humanitarian aid efforts in armenia
they also plan to hold events in the
coming weeks including vigils and
protests
to raise awareness locally for now
reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now